another integral that we can solve by
substitution of the right function
a trig function in this case they give
us x equals cos2 theta
so to work with this to change variable
i'll need to work out dx on d
theta which is negative 2 sine 2 theta
and now i'll have all my pieces to put
into here right
i've got my x's so i'm going to have the
integral of the square root of
1 plus cosine 2 theta on 1 minus
cos 2 theta now instead of dx
i'm going to put negative 2 sine 2 theta
d theta now i've changed my variable
that's good okay
now i've got a big square symbol here
and i want to get rid of it
by turning what's underneath the um the
the square root the radicand that's a
weird name we never use
into something that's squared so that i
can evaluate the square root now the way
you're going to do that is use the um
the double angle formula cos two theta
you can write that in a variety of ways
three ways but the two ones that are
important to us
are that you could say it's two cos
squared theta minus one or you could say
it's one minus
two sine squared theta okay now you can
see that a different one is going to be
appropriate for the
numerator and the denominator here we
want something that will get rid of that
one
here we want to get rid of the one but
we use a negative so what you're going
to choose what will be most helpful
is if i choose the 2 cos squared theta
minus 1 put that on the top that
negative 1 will cancel with that
here because i've got everything
reversed because of that negative i
should choose this one
and then this negative 1 will cancel
with that one and i'll be left with a
positive 2 sine squared theta
so what you end up with is 2 cos squared
theta on the top
and a 2 sine squared theta on the bottom
those two cancel of course then you've
got your
i'll put that minus 2 from here out the
front
and sine 2 theta i'm going to write that
as 2
sine theta cos theta using the sine
double angle the reason why is because i
anticipate
that this sign will cancel with this
sign once i evaluate the square root
okay now that that
negative 2 i'll leave out the front i'm
going to get
cos theta on sine theta
times 2 sine theta cos theta
with respect to theta and as i
anticipated those sines
cancel and then what you've got here is
negative 2 out the front
and i've got 2 cos squared theta
d theta now i can use the same identity
that i used up here
in order to turn this back into
something that's easier to integrate
namely a cos 2 theta
type angle in this case i'm going to get
1 plus
cos 2 theta with respect to theta all i
have to do
to see that is take that negative one
and move it over to the other side it
becomes plus one
okay so now i'm almost there i can
actually evaluate this integral
that one's going to turn to a theta that
cos 2 is going to turn to a
half sine 2 theta
and then you've got your constant of
course now what's going to happen here
well i might as well stick that 2 in to
get rid of that half
that's going to become just sine 2 theta
plus my constant and at this point i've
gotten to where i want to get rid of my
thetas and put it back
in terms of x's now how am i going to do
that
that 2 theta there i'll need to use a um
i usually need to use inverse trig here
so if i take cos inverse of both sides
within a restricted domain
i'll get that then what do i do with
this side 2 theta well again i'm
going to consider this cos this 2 theta
as an angle within a triangle
like so which only works within a
restricted domain 2 theta obviously has
to be acute
but it will still give us a a premium
function that will work
okay so if i've got cos 2 theta equals x
that's adjacent on hypotenuse and so by
pythagoras you can see
that's what the other side is equal to
so if i want sine 2 theta i want
opposite on hypotenuse will just be the
square root of that so i'm going to get
we tell said that that was negative cos
inverse and
using the triangle we got this plus the
constant
and that's it